estos manifestantes piden una
intervención militar como lo
mencionábamos citando un artículo de la
Constitución tiene esto algún fundamento
legal Y qué tan probable es que algo así
suceda
no primero no hay ningún fundamento
legal las fuerzas armadas no tienen
ningún rol en la institucionalidad
democrática brasileña tiene un papel
funcional de defensa del territorio
nacional de eventualmente sobre un
comando de las autoridades civiles
inclusive con la autorización del
Congreso cuando hay alguna convulsión
interna que las fuerzas ordinarias no
sean capaces de contar lo que te hemos
visto hoy Son sin manifestaciones
personalistas los derechos de
manifestación está previsto en la
constitución pero hay algunos abusos
como este de Los camioneros que cerron
la pasajen de civiles por por las
carreteras entonces las policías están
desbloqueando este escasos no a ninguna
posibilidad de una intervención militar
en fase de este tipo de prote
ahora porque arremeten contra el
Tribunal Superior Federal tiene esto
algo que ver con la atención que
sostenía el presidente bolsonaro con el
poder judicial Sí
vos sonaron es un populista autoritario
que desde este inicio de su mandato como
presidente
atacado de manera muy contundente las
Cortes superiores especialmente el
supremo tribunal Federal pero también
más resentimiento atacó a las urnas
electrónicas e a los Tribunal Superior
electoral responsable pelo pleito
electoral que se terminó Entonces como
el presidente Trump a fez de manera
preventiva una narrativa de
desliquimación de desacreditación tanto
de las urnas electrónicas cuanto del
tribunal y apoya su derrota en un
proceso legítimo que no cualquier
situación de violación por parte de las
urnas electrónicas e insatisfecho a no
reconocido la elección de Lula es sus
apoyadores entran están en las calles
reproduciendo un poco lo lamentable
comportamiento del presidente cree
entonces que si bolsonaro hubiera
reconocido explícitamente su derrota no
se estarían dando estos pedidos de
intervención Ah evidente
demoró 45 horas para que
ha hecho una manifestación de dos
minutos muy singela donde no ha hecho
una una un reconocimiento explícito pero
lo proceso ha movido porque su jefe de
la casa civil ha iniciado el proceso de
transición que es previsto que la
legislación brasileña entonces creo que
no tenemos ninguna consecuencia
significa más grave son manifestaciones
lamentables porque
van a de encontró a a a a Aunque
estableció las urnas en Brasil pero no
veo consecuencias políticas más graves
porque los sistemas políticos y ya dio
inicio a todo el proceso de transición
los reconocimiento por parte de los
presidentes de las cámaras diputados en
el senado del supremo tribunal Federal
de todas las la los reconocimiento por
parte de las Naciones democracias del
mundo Entonces ese es un proceso
Irreversible pero tenemos que convivir
con la insatisfacción de un grupo
bastante radicalizado que se formó al
hongo del gobierno bosolar